[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Поділля
Концеба]
Дехто називає мене інопланетянином.
Діма-інопланетянин.
Я не прив'язуюся до чужих думок.
[Дмитро Львов
Екобудівельник, дауншифтер]
Я той хто я є.
І начебто з цієї планети. [cміється]
Я сам з Одеси.
Працював у «тєлєку» 5 років.
Так вийшло,
що ми знімали знайомих-дауншифтерів.
Вони продавали квартиру в Одесі
і їхали жити у село.
А у мене тоді якраз криза була.
Нерозуміння, що з цим життям робити,
все задовбало.
Приїхав ввечері,
поїв полунички з городу.
Походив просторами.
Побачив величезне зоряне небо.
І зрозумів: це те, що я хочу.
Все кинув, продав камеру.
І купив на ці гроші будинок в селі.
Я переїхав,
а вранці одразу бабуся
прийшла знайомитися.
Принесла з собою молочка, яєчок.
Тут велика кількість переселенців.
В основному з Одеси.
Чоловік 30 живе в радіусі 10 км.
Ми почали між собою спілкуватися.
Всі ідейні, всі за здоровий спосіб життя.
Всі люблять робити щось руками.
І вже через рік-два утворилося ком'юніті.
Тепер регулярно відбуваються «сходняки».
Як на мене, тут є якась магія.
Навіть в напівзанедбаному стані
це місце як живе.
У ньому є якась родзинка.
Ми подумали, що було б класно зробити,
як зараз модно називати, еко-хостел.
Щоб люди могли приїжджати сюди
і насолоджуватися сільським життям
у відносно комфортних умовах.
Ми сюди прийшли і зрозуміли,
що не повинно бути кутів.
Насамперед закруглили кути.
Підготували, все розвалили.
Юра спорудив пічку.
Я почав ліпити і робити пластику
з того ж переробленого саману і глини,
які ми тут відшкрябали.
По суті це технологія мазанки:
плетений каркас,
замішується глина з соломою
(так званий «саман»),
і все обліплюється,
надається потрібна форма.
Зміцнюється паличками або дротом.
Всім, що знаходиться і може бути використано.
Все йде в справу.
Ось цей ось світильник
зроблений з банок для спини.
Просто вони зашліфовані, а всередині діоди.
Навіть вікна були звичайні
і ми їх заклали глиною.
Степлером навбивав скоб,
замазав саманом, зашпаклював.
І вони стали виглядати
набагато автентичнішими.
Сусід наш назвав це «округлізм-стиль».
Мені здається, це «неоукраїнський прованс».
Було дослідження,
що можна зробити з простором
і як максимально його використовувати.
Ось відмінна знахідка — подіум.
Він одночасно і шафа для речей,
і місце, де може розміститися
велика кількість людей.
Килим задає стиль всьому інтер'єру.
Це для любителів сільського ретро.
У багатьох виникають ностальгічні почуття.
Деякі хочуть навіть тут зупинитися,
тому що все як у бабусі,
як у батьків в селі.
Сюди навіть дівчинка приїжджала зимувати.
Приїхав я, вибрав будиночок.
А через два місяці
приїхала мама з молодшим братом.
І каже: «Ми теж хочемо жити в селі».
Я спочатку закляк,
я собі все по-іншому планував.
Що просто буду «залипати» якийсь час,
поки не визначуся,
куди я хочу направити вектор свого життя.
Але їх приїзд все кардинально змінив.
Мама змусила проводити воду,
робити санвузол в будинку.
І я потрапив в «будівельне рабство»
на кілька років.
Але за підсумком я їй за це дуже вдячний.
Тому що я приїхав криворуким хіпстером.
З великим его.
І за ці кілька років «прокачався»
до досить вмілого столяра.
Уже розбираюся в багатьох технологіях.
Я думаю, у цього місця світле майбутнє.
Просто потрібно цим займатися.
Це повинно перетворитися
в парково-розважально-оздоровчу spa-середу.
З різними банями,
з будиночками на деревах.
Це повинно приносити задоволення.
Адже це життя.
І якщо на це йде
велика частина твого часу,
а це тобі не подобається
і не приносить жодних дивідендів,
то який сенс цим займатися?
Кожен повинен зайнятися собою.
Розуміти, чого він хоче.
І вести гідний спосіб життя.
Навести порядок в себе на сходовому майданчику.
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Портян]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]